hey guys it's Jonah here so today I'm
going to answer one of the questions you
ladies have been asking me over and over
again should I exercise while on my
period I'm actually filming this video
right now while on my period so you know
what I feel like doing I feel like just
sitting on this couch and do absolutely
nothing I'm just kidding well I got
myself certified as a women's fitness
specialist under the National Academy of
Sports Medicine & ASM because I wanted
to understand us ladies better and for
me to share my knowledge and experience
with you guys we are so different
compared to men our body changes every
week and I've learned so much of the
cars so if you're interested in healthy
living if you like to inspire others to
get healthy I would encourage you to
check out of their online personal
training costs the NASM is currently
offering a 14-day free trial so you can
try it out and if you find that this is
the path that you want to go down then
by all means you can do the full cost
and become a certified personal trainer
yourself so ladies let's talk about
period and exercising sometimes when
you're on your period all you really
feel like doing is lying on the couch
and do absolutely nothing well I know
that feeling but what our body needs may
be exactly the opposite so to answer
your question yes we should and can
workout before and while on our period
what's most important is for you to
listen to your body and try not to give
excuses as well so if you feel
absolutely fine there is no reason why
you can't continue your workout as usual
your period should not help your
performance and you should not affect
your workout if however you do
experience mal cramps or discomfort then
you might want to avoid high-intensity
workouts or any exercises that will put
too much stress on your body go for
moderate to low intensity workouts try
Pilates or yoga that will help to relax
and stretch the entire body go for brisk
walking easy cycling dance
or even swimming although you might not
feel like doing any exercises this is
not an excuse to sit on the couch all
day long and do absolutely nothing you
got to push yourself and do some gentle
exercises it will only do you more good
so here are five reasons why you can and
should exercise before and while on your
period exercising will elevate your mood
and ease menstrual cramps I did not feel
like exercising at all for the past two
days but I had to talk to myself and
remind myself that exercising will only
make me feel better both physically and
mentally afterwards so I joined a
Pilates class yesterday and yeah that
totally made me feel so much better than
sitting on my bum just don't push
yourself if you feel nauseated having
excessive flow or experience severe
cramps take the day off and do gentle
exercises when you feel better the next
day another huge benefit of regular
exercising is something I've experienced
myself over the years I've combated
dysmenorrhea
which also means excessive period pain
when I was a teenager and did almost no
physical activity I would experience
excessive period pain almost on a
monthly basis the pain was so severe
that I would be lying and screaming on
my bed and I would just skip school and
I would experience constipation then
diarrhea and I have fainted several
times in the toilet before so for those
of you who have experience excessive
period pain I'm sure you would agree
that the pain can be so severe that you
can perform any normal activities when I
started getting into fitness and when I
started doing regular workout I noticed
that over the years I don't experience
severe period cramps or pains anymore
and in fact nowadays I barely
experienced any cramp
so do let me know in the comments below
if you do experience severe period pain
and if exercising has helped you over
the years for benefits reduce bloating
bloating is something we tend to
complain a lot about especially before
menstruation and it is caused by water
some of you might also experience excess
gas and also constipation I personally
do experience bloating several days
leading up to my period so I would wake
up in the morning look into the mirror
and go oh my god I feel like I've put on
five pounds overnight that is when I
know I will be getting my period very
soon
bloating is such an uncomfortable
feeling if that could leave me feeling
really irritated for the entire day and
for me the only thing that could get rid
of that is through exercising when we
exercise we sweat so we're also
releasing and getting rid of excess
water and reduce bloating it can also
help to prevent constipation and the
final benefit is reduced cravings if we
could we probably would want to eat
anything and everything before and
during our period I've filmed an entire
video just talking about period cravings
which I would recommend you to watch it
here in the video I spoke about the
common period cravings and why foods to
avoid and also tips to overcome period
cravings which include exercising a
research has shown that ladies who tend
to do regular exercises are more in
control over their period craving in
comparison to ladies who do not do any
physical activity this is due to the
feel-good endorphins released through
physical activities which can replace
food so ladies although you might feel
really shitty the best thing you can do
is to push through and do your workout
exercise gives you a natural endorphin
high it will elevate your mood is
menstrual cramps helps you to feel less
bloated reduce cravings and keep you on
track with a fitness goal you wouldn't
want to miss the entire week of doing
absolutely nothing so ladies get off
your bum get up and start moving if you
find this video to be helpful be sure to
give it a thumbs up and share it with
your girlfriends as well all the best
maybe you know I need to film okay I
need to
this is impossible
they be not by I need to fill maybe I
need some film no rusty this is always
the case when I try to fill my video it
takes at least half an hour to salt this
boy out
okay bye come on come on kissy-kissy
ouch